we have breaking news from the
University of Virginia where officials
say a gunman who killed three people is
still on the loose the shooting happened
late last night on the campus in
Charlottesville Virginia and police are
searching for a student who authorities
believe pulled the trigger Dan Schutte
of our Charlottesville affiliate wcav is
at the UVA campus where classes today
are canceled Dan good morning multiple
law enforcement agencies are looking for
a suspect they've identified as Chris
Darnell Jones Jr campus police warned
students of a shooting through their
emergency Network last night that
happened at around 10 45 p.m they
received reports of shots fired at an
on-campus parking garage minutes later
authorities ordered a shelter in place
at the grounds of the university and the
surrounding community and set a massive
search with multiple agencies was
underway after identifying the suspect
as Jones police released this picture of
Jones from the University's Athletics
website and lists him as a member of the
School's football team in 2018 when he
was a fresh in an email to the Campus
Community the school's president said
quote I am holding the victims their
families and all members of the
University of Virginia Community in my
heart today and we will make plans to
come together as a community to grieve
as soon as the suspect is apprehended
the president said in an email that
those are injured are receiving medical
treatment classes are canceled today for
CBS mornings on the ground of the
University of Virginia I'm Dan Schutte
Tony Dan Schutte thank you very much